i am not surprised to see the end of
trump's at least first four years ending
chaotically
since that is how they began and that is
how they went and that is why he was
elected in the first place to be a
disrupter
so why are people so shocked that he
continues to disrupt
all right this is the reuben report i'm
dave rubin and we are doing a quick
on the fly interview today because i
mentioned on the show the other day i
don't know who to trust
anymore i don't know who's making sense
i don't know who's looking at the world
with clear eyes and i went through my
mental rolodex
and megyn kelly popped up and megan you
agreed to do the show
just like that and here we are how you
doing
i'm doing well for you dave anytime
clear eyes
full heart can't lose all right well
here are my notes for today's interview
oh
and you're just like me pony barrett i
got nothing although my guys did tell me
this is this is gonna air on sunday
we're taping this friday afternoon so
people will have to bear with
you know if any little crazy vote got
changed or anything else but
generally speaking as we tape this on
friday afternoon how are you feeling
about the state of this election
the media portion of it the recount
portion of it
biden trump the whole damn thing
i have a lot of thoughts um a lot of
thoughts let's do them let's do them one
at a time
i am not surprised to see the end of
trump's at least first four years ending
chaotically since that is how they began
and that is how they went
and that is why he was elected in the
first place to be a disrupter
so why are people so shocked that he
continues to disrupt
uh right up to the last what appear to
be the last final moments of
you know his his if not his presidency
his you know the time
in his presidency before election um i
think trump has lost
i do i know people don't want to hear
that um but i think he's lost
and i think a lot of people are
struggling to
accept it right it's like a grief
process the first
first step is denial and i think
trump i'm not saying that he shouldn't
get we should do all the stuff we should
we should check out what's happening in
pennsylvania he should see those legal
challenges through we should make sure
we have a
wisconsin recount and a georgia recount
but my
assessment from where i sit out here is
there are not enough gettable votes
even if he can prove fraud or some
untoward process with the mail-in votes
to get him over the top anymore if that
that phase has passed
do you have do you have faith that the
numbers that we're getting
are real like do you have faith that not
only the people on the ground in
whatever state you want to pick whatever
city you want to
pick are are being honest and that is
being translated to us honestly through
the media do you have faith in that
not utter faith but enough faith i mean
these are the same people who did the
count four years ago
and he won so let's let's be real
they didn't just become fraudulent uh
you know vote counters in the past four
years
and they also hated him four years ago
it's not like they loved him they
thought he was gonna be full of love and
rainbows when he got into office
they wanted to kill him four years ago
and you know philadelphia is famous for
its voter fraud and so like these
these problems have existed long before
now
and what i'm seeing in the electoral
process is it to me it's akin to
like when we went hd and television
where everything looked just fine when
it was like there's a little fuzzy and
then like
when you could see it up close and
personal it was like my eyes like oh my
god
i didn't want to see this it's hideous
and that's what's happening with our
electoral process
it isn't perfect it's far from perfect
it's the best we have
should we do better can we do better yes
and yes hello florida let's just be like
florida
um but we're not right now and we're not
going to get it to the point of
ah now it's perfect and we can perfectly
know that every vote that was proper was
counted and everyone that wasn't
was not it's not going to happen people
that's not the way our system is built
so we're going to have to do good enough
that's how the system's set up
and the even the votes he's counting
even the ones he's like that was
fraudulently filled out or that's
you're talking about handfuls handfuls
here and there you know you're not
talking
about 70 000 votes that's going to get
him over the top in arizona
that's not going to happen and you know
the places where it's tightest
biden is ahead biden is ahead right now
and george a biden is ahead
um in a couple of these states that
trump is contesting so
i just think the odds of trump turning
this around
right now are infinitesimal and so we
i'm not saying it's totally impossible
but realistically if you want to know
what i think i think he's lost
and i don't think his legal challenges
or the recounts are going to amount to
much
yeah so so what do you think he'll do do
you think he just runs the table with
every legal recap
every every legal course of action and
just does absolutely
anything or do you sense that maybe at
some point if what you're saying is
right
that he will throw in the towel i know
throwing in the towel doesn't sound like
trump
and i also think he owes it to his
supporters who love him
and and don't trust these systems for
good reasons
to see these challenges through i have
no problem him stoking those fires and
getting in there and making sure
to the extent he can maybe it's his
final act as president
right before his lame duck period to
like disrupt yet another system to upend
it
blow it up and ultimately make it better
right tear it down so we can come back
better for the next four year period
um but i i support his his willingness
to challenge
these you know where he has good faith
evidence
of a problem like what happened in
pennsylvania with allowing
the mail-in votes to be postmarked on
election day something that was approved
by
judges and not legislators which is not
okay and the
court refused to take that challenge
they said get back to us if this becomes
an ongoing problem after the election
and if there's a split in the states
that we might have to resolve he should
proceed pursue that he should
but again it doesn't look like there are
enough votes in that pile
that could help him anyway i think he
should see it through i don't think he
should give up before he has to
but i think realistically when it
becomes clear that he's lost
we're gonna need the people who are
closest to him who he trusts
not the media which he doesn't for good
reason to sit him down and say
it's no longer about you this is about
the country
and there will be a peaceful transfer of
power
and while you can go out there and say i
have real problems with the way the
system
conducted itself and i don't know about
this vote i
am going to pass the torch and put
america first
to quote somebody we all know do you
think
that part of his calculation of of even
if he sees it
that he's lost like the challenges
aren't going anywhere that part of it
will be the burn it down thing
because you know even just a few minutes
before we started here i saw a tweet by
aoc and you know
in effect you know we're gonna have to
come for trump and he you know they keep
saying enablers
and the sycophants and whatever and it's
like you know a few weeks ago
robert rice who was in the clinton
administration talking about a truth and
reconciliation commission
and that these people love lists and all
of these weird things and it's like for
all the chance of locker up
it never happened there was no there was
nobody knocking on hillary's door and
that trump may feel
and i think actually for good reason
that that these people
whether the guy did anything illegal or
not they've created this monster
in their heads let's say and that they
will do things that are unimaginable
in in the american political landscape
well
i think yes they will it's not paranoia
when they really are out to get you
and that explains a lot of trump's
behavior i mean i think
the media is like so disgusted by his
rhetoric from the white house and
like it's not great i'm not going to
defend it but i understand where he's
coming from
they have been out to get him for more
than four years
the media is his enemy they
absolutely are his enemy and the
democrats
loathe him in a special way
and one does have to wonder if a lot of
these democrats think
the ends justify the means i mean that
we really have had a baseless attempt to
impeach the guy that was right on the
heels of a completely
made-up russia investigation and not to
mention all the
non-controversies the media fed off of
for the last four years
so he is right to totally distrust them
the pollsters have had it totally wrong
when it comes to trump all along
i do want to make a distinction between
the pollsters who predict vote
prior to the vote and the people at the
decision desks
who analyze for a living raw vote
tallies
two totally different animals okay so
just because we don't trust the
pollsters like nate silver
doesn't mean we shouldn't trust the fox
news decision desk but anyway trump
has a general distrust of these systems
that's well-founded
and so and i and so do his fans and
that's why i think people aren't being
nuts right now it's not crazy
conspiratorial people like knowing but
it's based on data it's based on
experience
and and to expect the left to understand
any of that
is too much to expect they won't there
isn't grace on the other side
i mean there's there's great guys like
andrew yang right who's saying all the
right things like be cool and like let's
not go too far and
whatever and then there's just jerks
like aoc you know or nancy pelosi coming
out and saying we have a mandate which
you don't even have close to amanda
and one other point on her the more you
say you have a mandate which you clearly
do not you lost house seats instead of
gaining them it looks like you're not
going to have control of the senate
you didn't get the blue wave at the
federal at the presidential level
the the more the republicans if they do
take over that senate are going to do to
stymie
every piece of joe biden's agenda there
will be no grace
on their side either so i actually read
your tweet about nancy pelosi in the
mandate on
on my show this morning and i was trying
to frame it in a way that that will give
people obviously a lot of my audience
you know likes trump so i was trying to
say okay if this doesn't
work if this doesn't end up the way you
want it to end up like what what are the
silver linings around this thing
and i agree with you that her tweet or
her comment was so over the top
that maybe it gets the republicans to
dig and then i'm starting to think you
know i'm not a statist
generally in like a traditional sense
but i'm starting to think
that maybe instead of the small
government that i really want
maybe we never really get to that but
maybe the best thing we could have is
sort of like an
endlessly stalemated government like
that that basically just
can't do anything and then what will
happen is every four years we'll have
the guy do
executive actions and then the next guy
will reverse him and that and that'll
just
be the way we're governed and i know it
kind of sucks and for those of us that
do this for a living it's like not
really what you want but like maybe in a
bizarre sense that's the last failsafe
that we have
does that make any sense stasis could be
could be okay
right i think that the democrats would
much have preferred stasis
to trump doing anything meaningful and i
think that's how the republicans are
feeling now i mean i
i my own sense of it is most republicans
aren't that scared of joe biden
the man because he has a 50-year history
of legislating from the middle
but joe biden is elderly and not totally
with it mentally from what we've seen
and i think a lot of people are worried
that he is just going to be the puppet
and people like aoc and nancy pelosi are
going to be the puppeteers and i realize
those two women don't have the same
agenda
but as far as republicans are concerned
neither is good um you know you're not
going to have
some moderate um you know joe manchin
pulling the strings on
on joe biden it's gonna be people like
that the squad and nobody wants a squad
getting in there and telling him what to
do
or just pressuring him so much that he
does it so i think stasis would be okay
but i think it could be worse than
stasis
it could be a bloody civil war sort of
if you will political civil war forgive
the reference
because um if they if they do go after
trump if they if
if they decide to go after him legally
and put him in jail and undo everything
and like you know completely go after
trump and his supporters
you know the senate does a lot
republicans control the senate and i
know we're looking at two runoffs in
georgia but georgia republicans have
never lost a runoff in the state of
georgia never
now i realize we're going to have a huge
money dump there to try to change that
this time around but
and georgia's changing it's becoming
bluer obviously but
the odds are on the gop side so let's
assume for now gop con
retains control of the senate they if
they retain control of the senate the
democrats do all those things
they're going to make it as ugly and as
acrimonious and as
unfortunate for the dems as possible a
lot of these cabinet choices have to be
they have to be confirmed by the senate
right like what if
what if a a justice uh god forbid dies
and you you need confirmation by the
senate like there there's a
lot the senate can do to stop a
president from getting
anything done and in two years we have
another election
and the democrats share of the house
majority i mean it's going down like
this
as we speak it's getting smaller and
smaller and it couldn't get down when
all of a sudden done to just a four-seat
advantage
by the dems if that happens they're
almost certainly going to lose control
in two years so
politics never stops yeah yeah you know
if you are just a complete prick
two and four years later it's gonna come
back at you right and then when you look
at some of the interesting numbers that
broke in different ways that the
that black men voted more than two times
as high for
a republican as they did last time and
black women it went up from
4 to 8 that's not a huge percentage but
doubling
is pretty good i saw something this
morning that 16
i think of muslims voted for trump like
all things that you just wouldn't expect
that
that uh lgbt support for trump actually
more than doubled so like there are some
interesting signs in the future
how worried are you just about general
like
trust in the whole damn thing like that
the same people who said
russia are now saying our election is
tamper-proof right
like that's the big one that i'm like
seeing the hypocrisy on right now you
guys ran around saying russia interfered
in our elections four years ago
now now you're telling us because you
got what you wanted apparently that the
system is perfect
so that people won't trust the electoral
system they already don't trust the
media system
that that basically you know all of our
the colleges
just the institutional level there is
just no
trust in anything anymore and i i can't
really fake it for people you know like
i wish these things were better but i
don't think they are
well i some of that concerns me but
most of it doesn't um i think for
example i think joe biden's not going to
pack the supreme court and that's good
because that would have been a massive
move that would have ruined the supreme
court that would have been the end of
the supreme court
and that would would have been a
catastrophic breakdown of systems what
if it ain't what if it ain't joe because
i'm with you on that i think joe
actually no there's not support for it
within the democratic party or writ
large there isn't so you think you think
by him getting in it's it's fed them
enough that they won't have to do like
the the crazy i even think if you know
if kamala harris were at the top of the
ticket right now
and ascending to the white house it
wouldn't happen there isn't support for
it in the united states there
the the people don't want it you know
the fdr couldn't get it through when he
controlled his party democrats
controlled the house and the senate
and he was hugely popular well the
support right now is 20
lower for packing the court than it was
back then it's not going to happen
people don't want it these politicians
aren't politically suicidal
so that was a good talking point by
jeffrey toobin who really should have
been more focused on how to work his
zoom
than writing provocative articles in the
new yorker about [ __ ] that's never going
to happen
um and it's i don't think joe biden's
going to do that i think the reason he
wouldn't answer that when he was running
is because the answer was no
it was to protect his left flank you
know him from his left
flank not to protect himself from the
right but
i also kind of think that distrust in
some agencies can be good and it's it's
not all destructive
you know like i think the media needed
to be destroyed
and and now it will rebuild in some way
shape or form i mean
i really think i've said this to you
before that the journalists
they've been on a kamikaze mission ever
since trump it didn't start with trump
but like
he he's the it was that was the real
mission they've been on a kamikaze
mission to take him down
and it wound up being a thing where they
did kill themselves
and in the end it does appear they took
him with them
it does appear they brought him down
because if you don't think the media
played a role in people's perceptions of
trump these past four years as
controversial as he is
legitimately ben i don't mean to give
him a full pass on all the crazy stuff
he's done
but the media did so much of it so they
they are they are a force i don't want
to say for evil that's too strong but
they're not to be trusted and they're
not what they used to be and they're not
honest about it
so they needed to be destroyed and we'll
see what comes up so maybe that's true
in the fbi
they needed to be unmasked as this
political organization i had complete
trust in james comey
david i did i was like jim comey
i you know the guy wrong yeah
and i'm grateful for having that you
know that that
mask pulled off and so but but it's a
problem
i can't totally dismiss the dismantling
of destruct of trust in some of these
organizations
right like well that's what i'm saying
i'm i'm down with the distrust stuff i
don't i don't think they
they deserve our trust anymore but the
problem is that it sort of only got
halfway
in other words if trump loses well then
they've been on mass but they're about
to rebuild you can already feel it a
little bit like
they didn't fully get us so here we go
again something like that no no i don't
think that's right
because they never lost trust with the
democrats they've had it
i mean we're just going to a more
fractured media world like the country
used to have when we were founded and
for
100 years thereafter where you know left
has its sources and the right has its
sources but one great thing trump did
was
make very clear that virtually everybody
is on that
first side virtually everybody is
actually fighting
for democrats there's not a republican
in the country
left i think that thinks cnn
is fair and objective news maybe some
people who really don't pay attention to
the news might
might still think that but republicans
haven't been fooled
you know the mask has been pulled off so
that's a good thing
you know and i don't think they're gonna
i think they're gonna be very defensive
of joe biden i think
quietly the washington post democracy
dies in darkness
can you just get pulled off the bus
it's no longer dark so we don't need
yeah
but i think all that's great and it
gives the audience
you know it's like let me let me put it
to you this way
if you have a friend who's a real jerk
and you didn't you didn't know it
um i've been thinking of my one friend's
example so i'll give you this
friends of ours interracial couple the
husband's black
that the wife is white and after the
george floyd thing
they were very upset because one of
their white friends called them up and
said
how are you doing i hope you're okay and
then
they saw they found out oh no you know
what i can't tell the whole story
because it will reveal who it was
but it was somebody who they thought was
a friend and who they had helped out
with their with respect to their kid
getting into college they had done a lot
to help him
and basically the guy got outed as
repeatedly saying the n-word
and really racist stuff about black
people so
they were shocked they were horrified
and i said to them you know what this is
a good thing
because that was the reality yesterday
and you just didn't know
what it's better today to know and and
then act accordingly it's not
it's hurtful to find out but it's not
better to be in the dark and that's how
i feel about the media
and these organizations which really are
politically driven but we didn't know it
may hurt to learn it or not but it's
better to know and then act accordingly
yeah yeah i'm with you on that well what
do you think about the the big tech
element then
also that you know going forward that
at least even though they did nothing i
mean i kept saying this the whole time
you guys are having these hearings
and it's great to see ted cruz who i
totally like and respect
it's great to see him grill jack but you
guys are doing it six days before an
election
and we're pretending that this is in
theater are you worried that okay
trump was sort of the last thing that
was stopping big tech from doing
whatever it might want to do
i i don't know what exactly what it
wants to do but now
without that threat of we're going to
regulate you
whatever it might you know break you up
stuff that i don't particularly want
them to do
uh are you worried that they're just
gonna go all in and
and silence the real resistance which
will be you know the remaining free
thinkers
yes i am worried about that i i don't
have the solution to that either i
i am worried i think one of the sad
things but the realities over the past
20 25 years is the republicans have
shown themselves to be very good at
winning elections
maybe not in this particular case for
the white house but in general they win
elections and
very bad at fighting the culture wars
and
it's unfortunate because now the
democrats control
the media hollywood um
academia big tech and
half the country doesn't feel
represented at all
in almost all of the information that
comes back to them publicly
like sports forgot to mention them so
you turn on the television and watch a
sports game
or get the news or watch the oscars
or the vmas whatever it is and
now you're getting woke ism shoved down
your neck and you're being told you're a
racist if you happen to be a republican
you like trump or even just if you're a
republican these days and
that you know you sent out a tweet that
is totally legitimate
and maybe just opinionated or a news
story being reported by that
new york post censored censored censored
you know your viewpoints are you're
being told they're bad by everyone
that has control of the public
microphones and i do think it leads
people to be like
am i insane am is everything i think
it's a problem i think big tech is part
of the problem i really wish we
would see somebody like peter thiel you
know who you know
he's gonna have to actively create a new
twitter and a new facebook and
like there needs to be a real other
digital forum out there
that represents the other half of the
country because i just don't think
they've got much of a future on the
existing platforms well the irony is
if trump loses and then it finally gives
him the impetus to be like okay i'm
going to another platform or i'm
starting my own platform that's how the
platform will
will work right like that ultimately
would be it no you don't
you don't think that would be enough no
i think that'll be like i mean with all
due respect sean hannity starting his
own network
like you know you know what you're gonna
get you're not gonna get real analysis
that now that's
no no i don't mean i don't mean you'll
get analysis i mean if trump is just
like all right i'm going i'm going to
parlor
or i'm going to locals or wherever that
it would be like everyone would go there
just
because he's still the show in a way oh
no questions yeah i don't mean that he's
going to create some non-partisan
network or something
i i'm not like conservative media is
well represented in the digital world i
get that but when it comes to these main
the main platforms out there i mean
facebook is it gives a little bit more
play but they're
they're censoring a lot of stuff too but
if you could have a real and i know
there's parlor i'm on parlor but it's
just
it's not what twitter is and i don't
know that it's going to be
you need a real player with a lot of
money to to create the platform and back
it and somebody with a spine of steel
like rupert murdoch to say
i don't need to be loved at the cocktail
parties i'm going to let this be a real
forum
for mainstream conservative thought in
other words
we don't need alex jones on there okay
but like
dave rubin does not need to get censored
right and
i i that's my only thought because i
you're not going to change
jack dorsey you're not going to change
facebook you're not going to change
these big tech organizations
for whom it's like deeply ideological
they think it's the difference between
good and evil you know it's not just
about getting biden elected it's about
silencing the rest of these racists did
you see that clip from sunny hostin on
the view
yeah unbelievable that
that embodies how they think the the
left wing and i don't even mean
progressives i know you used to be one
most professors i know are totally
normal and mainstream and they don't
believe in any of this nonsense
it's the quote left with the capital l
who are
insane in the way they see the other
half of the country and sunny hosting
just
put it on display where it was like
these at least
half the country i'm not going to say
they're racists
yeah but there isn't they'll see the
races but at least
half the country voted for him
notwithstanding
his racism his sex sympathism his
xenophobia his transphobia
and then uh another woman on the panel
sarah i don't remember her name but
she was like how can you say that you
know people vote in their own
self-interest all the time pocket book
issues and so on
doesn't make them bad doesn't make them
racist and the response was
no because this is about we the people
and we are supposed to behave as a
collective
and do what is right it's one of those
things dave i was like oh my god i wish
so badly for the first time in my life
that i were sitting on the view
i would have loved to said to her i i
get it totally
and just out of curiosity i'm wondering
because like there's a lot of people who
really feel like
for example um abortion is murder
and it's actually killing babies and
that's wrong
and what would be right would be to ban
it outright
and if you don't support that you are on
the wrong side you're in favor of
murder and and we the people respond you
to behave as a collective
right like i could go on for you know
give me five other examples like
the outrage and by the way let's look at
the southern border you know the people
down there who have had family members
killed by people illegally coming across
with drugs and
and weapons uh who have lost jobs to
people who are here unlawfully in the
country
they have real reasons for wanting a
great border wall and for cracking down
on illegal immigration
and if you don't support it you're the
one who doesn't care about life and the
well-being of your fellow citizens and
we the people who died and made her
king of we the people right it's like do
you think that's how they think
do you think they'll ever stop that
thing like that in many ways what you
just described there
that is the thing that most
the rest of us are fighting we don't
have to make it about sunny but that
thing and it's been so successful and
and as we're talking potentially is
about to dethrone donald trump
why would they stop doing it they're not
going to
they're not going to and i agree with
the headlines this week that said wokism
was dealt a blow during this election
because he saw
you know his numbers as you pointed out
with all these minority groups go up
people
the minority groups like it more than
they used to not less
like four years of ubiquitous media
coverage telling them he's awful
racist bigot all the stuff and that
they're awful if they
like him so that didn't work oh and by
the way i mean even just today there was
a congressman
a democratic congresswoman who was
saying uh defund the police
killed us killed us that is why we went
down in the house instead of up
and if we don't abandon that ridiculous
messaging we're going to
see a bloodbath in two years so wokism
you know the messaging was proven to be
a failure when it comes to electoral
politics
but that won't deter them that's not
going to stop anything
but for the reasons i was saying it's
ideological
it makes them feel like better people
superior
i don't know if it's their guilt if it's
just the virtue signaling makes them
feel great about themselves in bed at
night when they judge other people and
and decide they're all bad
so we're gonna have to deal with it and
the people who don't believe
in this bs culture and there's so many
people in the center right who don't
either look at the harper's leather
letter look at people like andrew
sullivan who hated trump but you know
he's completely taking a stand against
this baloney
they're going to have to speak up the
people who are against it i know they're
afraid
i know you can get fired now for the
most ridiculous reasons trust me i know
um we're going to have to start taking
risks otherwise we're all going to go
down
we're going to go down together on this
war yeah on a
personal note as you were watching the
election and and you're not
in the big studio and doing all that
stuff that you've done in the past
did you did you enjoy it more in a weird
way because you could just kind of watch
it and be on your couch or
were you on your couch where were you i
was yeah i was doing a bunch of hits
from here my living room
so i will say oh right you were you were
on daily wire right before me that night
you were you were home yeah i saw you
okay
yeah yeah so no can i tell you honestly
that's the first time that i've actually
missed being on tv
since i went off tv i loved those big
election nights and i
i think i know how to anchor them well
you know and i it's one of those things
where
if you're a strong pitcher and you see
somebody else pitching in the big game
you're like
hmm i wish i could be doing it so that
was like one of the first nights i think
that i actually thought oh i'd love to
be out there but
that's not to not to disparage anybody
who was out there just that i sort of
missed throwing my fastball
yeah so so what's next then for the me
uh megan kelly media empire if you
missed that
since i sent something you just said you
missed something
not at all no no no i i love what i'm
doing i'm i am
loving my podcast it's like i'm home i
chose right this is exactly right for me
it's a new forum it's one in which i can
use all aspects of my personality you
know it's like i'm i'm loving it
but that doesn't mean it can scratch
every itch but i have no desire to go
back to
fox or you know cable news at all i you
know as you know i left it for very good
reasons
11 9 and 7 right now and they're more
important to me than
taking care of that yeah i don't think
that i asked you this
when i had you on a couple weeks ago but
what is your sort of
philosophical or religious
like what is your like the thing that's
beneath politics that kind of keeps you
sane throughout this because when we're
talking about
the people that use this in a religious
nature and how wokism
has has caused so much destruction and
cause people to become believers who
otherwise usually aren't believers in a
traditional sense
i find the only people that are making
sense to me these days are people that
come at it
from some sort of belief aspect i'm not
they can have very various versions of
it but like what is
like beneath just your political outlook
of life
well it's it's more like it's above my
political outlook of life
i just feel like politics is over here
and i'm here
i don't this is like something we talk
about so it's not
it it's not who i am it's not it's not
really that important to me i have to
get involved because it
brings up important fights that one must
fight and
and i cover it you know as a as a
journalist and a commentator
but when i i am a woman of faith i'm not
particularly
observant in my catholicism but i was
raised catholic and i have that moral
imprint on me
um and i believe in god and i totally
believe in an afterlife and a higher
power
and i i guess i just believe what we're
here for is our human connections
and not any of this bs this is this is
small
stuff that people use to who enjoy
divisiveness they enjoy hostility and i
really believe a lot of them have
too little fulfillment in their own
lives and they you know the smaller your
life gets the more you feel the need to
to fill it with something else be it
drama
be it anger fighting
i'm not in that boat i i am filling the
main picture
over here p-i-t-c-h-e-r my children my
husband my marriage
my friendships myself my my you know my
enjoyment
in life and then politics over here and
take a swim over and i'll fight where i
need to fight
but i just think people who have nothing
to like remind them
it's just a limited time we're here
together um
make make bad choices and i'll put one
period on it
i interviewed adam carollo recently who
i just adore yeah me too
and he said it's such a in such a good
way he said i have no time
for people who obsess over people who
are
generally good but sometimes say
controversial things
and and he because i was asking him how
is he how's he best friends with jimmy
kimmel
right who like doesn't seem to really
like conservatives and adam pretty much
is
like how does that work and
he just sees everybody in terms of like
look that's not a bad person
there who's like doing good things and
even like aoc
right she's not a bad person she's young
she's a whipper snapper she got herself
elected to congress
from being a bartender i mean on some
love you got to respect that you don't
have to agree with a word she says
politically and you don't have to like
her judgments of other people
but like should we be focused on tearing
down
let's see the civilian aocs of the world
no
like why don't we get so upset about
them they might be admiring minor
irritant
you know like sonny host and i was just
ripping on her because she's got
hostility for everybody
do we really need to worry about the
sunny houses no we should fight the
political battles
just don't get so upset personally over
these people and like you know what
when it's coming into your life and it
has a pop the power to like fire you
or make you lose your job or make
endanger your children
you gotta perk up and you gotta pay
attention but you don't have to get
personally
offended by everything somebody else
stands for
you know you did it to me last time and
you did it this time which is you know
how to end an interview because we could
keep going here and talk more about
politics or the election but i think
that that was it that was it i'm not
going to drag out anything else
that was just perfect so we are going to
link uh to the podcast down below
thanks for taking subscribe you got to
subscribe oh subscribe it's very
very important to subscribe and uh and
enjoy the weekend megan and you know
don't think about politics the whole
time have fun with the kids and the dog
that's the plan the husband and the
husband and
hopefully we'll we'll do this in real
life soon see you soon
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell